[Musique]
le projet de land art est un projet qui
ont magnifié avec une convention avec le
jardin botanique depuis quinze ans et
dont chaque année donc on garde le la
thématique du land art et chaque année
on cherche une cinématique donc cette
année pour les 15 ans on a fait un
projet autour d'eux les empreintes
digitales traces land art c'est une
manière de faire de l'art avec avec la
nature et donc ici au jardin botanique
et à la réunion générale en a on a la
chance d'avoir une nature juste
exceptionnel c'est entreprend des 50
classes qui participent au projet chaque
année ce sont des élèves de primaire
donc 2
de la circonstance les circonscriptions
de ça le front national donc par sa
technique du ciel aux tic dans le celtic
dances procéder de deux photos avec une
solution photosensible c'est grâce au
soleil on peut imprimer les les
empreintes de feu il ya trois classes
qui a eu envie de travailler sur ce
procédé
projet permet d'emmener tout le monde
d'en mener tous les élèves parce que si
vous voyez chaque élève à porter son
oeuvre dati 25 25 élèves chacun a sa à
son heure il sait aussi c'est pareil
donc ça permet d'emmener tout le monde
et de et le land art particulièrement
permet justement de se recentrer sur soi
et donc sa danse
dans le drame tout dans les clé dans la
mélodie
[Musique]